bryce harper is back in the lineup yeah
that'll ease some of the tensions of
what happened last night tom but you
know you don't get over that loss until
the first pitch of today's game but yes
bryce harper is back good start for
spencer howard an 11th and a third
inning so far 17 strikeouts nine walks
nine hits
so far for spencer i know he's looking
forward to uh getting out there and
getting out there for an extended period
of time three-two pitch
swing gonna miss that's pretty cool to
see 95 low in the zone
one out here in the first one on two
outs
and josh bell the batter no score here
in the top of the first spencer howard
out of the stretch
kicks and comes home the pitch swung on
hit weekly towards short mayton circles
behind it he's got it fires it to first
and bell retired and so are the mats no
runs no hits a walk in a man left and
we'll go to the bottom of the first joe
ross to the mound at the bank so we'll
see how much joe ross utilizes the
change up today justin coming off a
rough month of may on the season two and
five with a 5.40 era
oh double herrera drives this one to
right
will it have the distance it will not
herrera thought he got it juan soto has
it in his glove bryce harper a national
league mvp with the nationals in 2015.
three straight from joe ross to seymour
working nicely for the nationals
right-hander in a 1-2-3 first inning
kyle schwarber leads off for the gnats
and that pitch right there that is a
beautiful curveball dropped right off
the table for the second strikeout and
one out here in the second it'll bring
up victor robles
popped up over near third base
alec baum is under it
and he makes the catch no runs no hits
and one man left reese hoskins philly's
first baseman will lead off with an
11-game hitting streak here's hoskins
out to shallow center robles coming in
and a nice running catch right on cue
right on cue well that's why victor
robles is at the big league level
spectacular defense here's mccutcheon
had himself a nice night last night
another ground ball to trey turner
joe ross doing a nice job early on
tonight in philadelphia pitcher joe ross
will lead off for the nationals then the
top of the order
ground ball firmly up the middle
joe ross has his second
three-game hitting streak
of the young season so it's one-on-one
as howard has his sign the right-hander
to the belt turner not running curveball
inside and that one hit him did not hit
the bat it hit him the phillies are
going to go to left-hander suarez here
an early call to the bullpen here juan
soto is going to be the first to face
him
soto ground ball right side and it's
through gene segura
we've talked about the phillies defense
being poor this season it cost them big
time
that could have been an ending ending
double play instead it scores a run trey
turner is in and the nationals have a
one-nothing lead 1-0 swinging a ground
ball
and to shadow right segura's got it gets
up fires to hoskins who got back for the
bag in time so could have been worse
certainly could have been better one run
across for the nationals it'll be nick
maton the shortstop left-handed batter
first start of the series now the 1-1
swinging a high drive to left center
field this one is deep schwarber back
near the track edge of the track makes
the catch out there in left center for
out number two here's the pitcher ranger
suarez
drops the barrel sends it out to right
field and there's juan soto joe ross
dealing at the bank today nine up nine
down ross does have a base here today in
fact he has the only hit today got him
all right so the two errors
don't harm him except to make him throw
a few more pitches go to the bottom of
the fourth one nothing nationals go to
the
bottom of the fourth philly's still
looking for a base runner top of the
order second time through here against
joe ross
early swing again
they have been very aggressive first
pitch out on the ground from herrera
bring up gene sugurup shoots it the
other way and it handcuffs josh bell
it's contagious that's going to be
bell's first error of the year oh and
two the count on bryce harper joe ross
kicks in the pitch it's way inside did
it hit him oh it did it got him on the
leg and harper in some pain he goes down
to both knees
[Applause]
his time getting his gloves off giving
him some extra time to paint out we'll
find out his next couple steps first and
second one out and here comes rhys
hoskins
that one's looped out to left center
field that's going to be a tough play
turner is out there he's not going to
get it segora scores the throw goes to
second rbi single for hoskins
and the phillies tie it up
it's a 1-1 game still just two outs and
a chance to
take a lead brings up andrew mccutchen
oh yeah fly ball to left field schwarber
going back to the wall
it's gone
a three-run home run for mccutcheon
and the phillies take a 4-1 lead here in
the fourth a little slider that just
didn't slide much from joe ross man was
that a pretty swing by andrew and much
needed who wins oh dusty did scissors
cut paper again double play depth for
the phillies the batter is juan soto and
a cold strike three on the outside
corner beautifully placed change up and
there are two outs
here's josh bell they have the pitch and
a called strike three on the inside
corner he threw another change up this
time to the righty and he gets
back-to-back strikeouts and the side is
retired here in the fifth inning and joe
ross back out there another one-two
swinging a tip meiton down on strikes
joe ross's two-seam fastball has been
sharp today that will bring up ranger
suarez
another good two-seamer back-to-back
strikeouts from joe ross here in the
fifth brings up victor robles
that one's hit toward third softly to
boom and the inning is over no runs no
hits and one man less here's mccutcheon
the big hit in the game a three-run
homer on a hanging slider in the fourth
ross at the letters coming set ryomuto
running the pitch strike three called to
throw down the tag by harrison double
play strike him out throw him out alex
avila has had three caught stealings
here in this two-game series and he guns
down rio muto for the second time in two
games juan soto will come to the plate
looking for his first hit and he hits it
towards second base that should be two
there's one and two that's a four six
three double play and a sigh of relief
from gene segora and a smile on his face
will be josh bell kyle schwarber and
starlin castro to bat as bell rips this
one out to left field that'll leave the
yard
josh bell has homered from the right
side of the plate and the nationals are
now down two here in the eighth high
velocity leading to a very high exit
video 110 miles per hour off the bat 404
feet from josh bell eighth home run of
the season starlin castro with a base
hit to center keeps the line moving for
washington now alex avila is coming up
that one's out to center field not deep
here comes herrera he makes the catch
one out
here in the eighth inning
with a good jump and
i thought that was dropping and now ryan
zimmerman will be summoned off the bench
swing and a miss
drew mccutter he got him some heavy
lifting from alvarado an inning in
two-thirds first and third nobody out
and bryce harper that one's out toward
right center that's going to drop her
face in one rut is in sigour is on his
way to third rbi single for harper
that's one insurance run and that leaves
juan soto as the last man to get
and a cold strike three throw him a
change up knee-high
and the ball game is over